after a few more days without cleaning
you'd start to experience some pain
yeah the soles of your feet would be
cracked you'd have itchy flaky patches
of skin developing between your toes
you'd start to feel tenderness
yeah you'd have developed a planter wart
and this would be different than the
bacteria and fungi you've been dealing
with it's a viral infection
these wounds could eventually develop
into a life-threatening staph infection
like MRSA
if left untreated necrotizing fasciitis
or flesh-eating bacteria could destroy
the skin fat and tissues over your
muscles
and if the infection entered your
bloodstream you could experience sepsis
organ failure or even death